this was the moment the war came to a
shopping center in a kiev suburb and
turned it into a smoldering ruin
instantly
with a multiplex theatre fitness club
stores and fast food restaurants it was
a big draw for surrounding apartment
blocks also damaged by the late night
missile strike
people in those blocks left traumatized
and wondering how their local mall could
in any way be a military target
i saw huge blast ain't lit up my room i
lived just here in front of it the blast
threw me of the bed
some were too close to the blast an
explosion which sent debris raining down
for several hundred meters all around
for many there's disbelief at how a
neighbor with such close cultural and
religious links could act like this
the russians have exhausted my limits
for love we call as king david did for
righteous punishment
from ukraine's president another appeal
for the world to come to his country's
aid with economic retaliation against
russia
please don't sponsor weapons of war for
the country of russia no euros for the
occupiers close all your ports to them
don't send them your goods
with much of russia's invading army
being held on different fronts after
apparent setbacks it seems to be relying
more on rocket and missile attacks able
to reach all parts of ukraine
hypersonic missiles are super precise
very precise and we destroyed
underground ammunition stocks the
hypersonic missiles were fired from 1
000 kilometers and only took 10 minutes
a russian deadline for ukrainian forces
and the besieged ruins of mariupol to
surrender was ignored
there have been continued problems for
some of the thousands of people still
inside the city to get out but
humanitarian corridors agreed between
the two sides have been operating
elsewhere in ukraine
still in the south mikhail remains a
hotly contested front line and the link
to the far more strategically important
city of odessa
a house there destroyed by shell fire
with more shells falling in the seas off
a shoreline that could become the next
battleground in this seemingly
relentless conflict rob mcbride al
jazeera level